well our next guests sang their way onto
the scene in 2010 in their perfect
harmonies have helped them sell over a
million records since now British vocal
harmony group the overtones are
celebrating the release of their sixth
album let's take a listen to one of the
songs
[Music]
so
so for cash
Oh
[Music]
so tired
[Music]
well lucky Mike mark and Daren the
overtones as you can see are with us now
welcome or welcome had a sneak preview
of the new album last night had a little
listen it's very soulful isn't it it is
did you have a little dance around the
living room as well this happened
possibly we were struck by incredible
sadness earlier this year with the loss
of light our bandmate and our brother
and our best mate Timmy motley are so
and we were making this album as a 5 but
we after till he died we did come back
to the drawing board as like boys doing
do we do this and so we we did and we're
we released it last week and we're so
delighted our fans are so delighted but
it like we're the overtones we need to
start the party and that like we always
do but this is a very particular out in
this one because it's also a fond
farewell to the overtones has a 5 into
our beloved night to me yeah how do you
even start to deal with that because
it's you know when you've been formed as
a 5 and it's actually you know just as
such a solid groom in South London you
have a the best the best thing for us to
do to be honest with you was to get back
in the studio and do what we do you know
it was all part of the grieving process
and all part of the healing process at
the same time and like lucky said we
feel like we've made a beautiful album
that does it does it justice that you
know I found a proud of Timmy will be
proud of his family are proud of so
we're we're happy with it and is that
partly sort of a tribute to him to
complete it because he was in the
exceptional actually that song that he
just plays Save the Last Dance was kind
of like I said we were arranging the
band with with Timmy so that's taking on
quite a lot of significance for us on
the album and they started off as quite
a mid-tempo quite true to the original
actually and now it's kind of this sort
of sentimental ballad which I mean it's
one of my favorites on the album
what about what intrigues me with with
your sort of music is about it's not
what you would class in the modern hears
being you know sort of popular in the
Indus in that pop sense but the fact
that you've you've sold so many records
it's touched a lot of people's
fascinating which has been like when
like you said before like a million
album sales and we still sort of go get
the giggles when we hear that and we're
incredibly proud but yeah you know these
classic songs from classic decades and
classic eras and it just makes people
happy like at our tours they're up if
people aren't out of their seats by the
second song dancing we're not doing our
job properly and so like we've got a big
tour coming up November December come on
down we're back on the road it'll be
good to be back on the road and you have
been quite brave about your song choices
I mean there's some people that you
don't dare to cover everything clean
you've got I say a little prayer and she
is right up there but she's my hero it
was amazing did you enjoy it
yeah I enjoyed your bird thank you we
thought can we do this like she's Queen
she's the queen of soul it's like to
delight for lads cover a wreath of
Franklin it's like but it's been really
nice though you know I guess I said the
proofs in the pudding people are really
enjoying that song so I'm glad you did
as well I don't think any any male
version exists or that song either we do
that often but also you know as looking
touch understand we've got a cover of a
Spice Girls song and again it's one of
those things where you sit down in the
studio and you go can we should we you
know it's it's it's one of those kind of
songs that a male vocal group has
certainly never touch so and of course
yeah of course it was that the whole
sentiment behind that song and many
others in the album it's goodbye goodbye
so you know that I mean this album had
to be a completely sentimental in so
many different ways and yeah that song
among others it just perfect what I
never quite understand particularly with
male harmony groups is how you make that
sound
so cohesive magic but are you doing it
into the break that it's just like you
can't hear four voices at all it just
becomes this one unified sort of you
think glorious sound that's why the UK's
number one harmony it's hard work it's
hard work you know like nothing comes
nothing comes easy you know you've got
to work hard at it and and I think
that's part of the reason for the
success that we've had over the over the
last eight years we're coming out to a
decade now you know we work hard we've
been lucky boys along the way you know
there's been lots of opportunities that
have been put in front of us based on
you know the music that we've been
releasing so you know how you do get the
harmony together just a little stomp
we could do a little bit of um this is
live
[Music]
very even friends then somebody means
beauty and fabulous thank you guys
you're really good really good to see if
thanks very much